hey guys we're about to head to brunch
but I wanted to tell you what I'm gonna
be vlogging with today I Jun boxing of
the EOS m3 it's a new newer
Canon mirrorless camera and I got a 22
millimeter lens that I'm gonna be
putting on right now I'm using I think
it's 18 to 55 so we're gonna swap that
out put this one on and then I'm gonna
try this little rode microphone it's one
of the many ones so it's a little bit
smaller this gonna be a great vlog it's
gonna be like we're shooting a feature
film at the Cheesecake Factory so we
know how the 22 millimeter lens on and
we're gonna head to brunch Maddie you're
so cute this is such a great depth of
field mmm look at this yeah but the
focus is still really slow on this
camera but man it looks good good wow
that's a little excessive okay how's our
audio how's this sound we got the
microphone on now you know the g5x they
ended up doing the flip screen this way
definitely should have done that with
this one because this doesn't it's just
what do you what are you doing okay oh
we're late we are heading to the
Cheesecake Factory to enjoy a nice
brunch joining us will be Edie and Jeff
and Francesca and Santino I miss Maddie
Oh Francesca Santino coming yeah man
this is a whole squad trip huh I feel
like it's gonna be really busy we're
gonna get a table well hopefully
someone's there taking care of it Hey
open it
um if you'll notice there may be a
slight coffee dripping she goes all the
way down the back of the car I put my
coffee on top of my roof and then I
drove probably a mile and then I
realized it was there and then it
spilled so I pulled over to the side of
the road got my coffee and it was half
full and I just drink it but I was a
good sorry your name and it was 5 a.m. I
was not happy well this will happen no
one was there to witness it and I was
too tired to film
and light a little concerned about the
microphone because it's bouncing a
little so I don't know if you guys are
able to hear that squats going up on
Saturday they're comfortable chewy
everywhere
they're called adidas ultra boost does
that have anything to do with like easy
or whatever his name is I mean it's easy
Zardoz but thank you I like liquor it's
dope
you got tagged on where's the Cheesecake
Factory now we've got some coffee we're
having a really great Sunday Saturday
brunch was like I drove three hours to
get over here three hours to go to
cheesecake from tritiated 45 okay but
there's so many places to go but then
there's me like long wait this place
looks brand-new
are you into that Instagram photo yeah
keep it
I tagged you guys 60fps what do you
think I like it looks good I like your
mic you guys can't see what you look
like but actually I showed you like put
your phone off the show I have nothing
else to really say I know no food what's
going on he's now moved on to 60 frames
a second so if you guys notice the
difference in quality or lack of quality
because I don't know what it looks like
can I get anything else free man what's
that mean that's Wiz Khalifa what do you
think it is I get it it's probably got
something to do with smoking oh yeah
here comes
alright guys that's it for today hope
you enjoyed this wonderful random vlog
from the Cheesecake back sorry I don't
even know what I filmed oh you know the
Cheesecake Factory now did you go to
your mystery event I don't want to talk
about it he doesn't talk about it but
Matt's doing some some secret things
it's your secret the secret I'm on a
mission from God so Maddie got so
excited because he saw me come in the
house and Francesca was holding him and
he took a tumble it looks like he's
wearing lipstick you a treat look honey
but it breaks my heart
Maddie has training on Wednesday are you
excited for your trainer
Maddie hey sit down let me see that
belly okay bye yeah look at you guys do
a little zoom in and I take a shot whoo